Borders are reasonable.
How about that?
The law is the border that stops someone
from stealing your
laptop.
If it's an apple laptop,
what's the sort of laptop that has
social justice warrior would carry and
then the social justice warrior is going
to be very irritated if you happen to
purloin their laptop and then you might
point out to them,
you know it's a border that protects you
from having that thing taken and they
say,
well,
the borders should be open.
It's okay man,
no problem,
and you hand over that laptop right now
and everything else you own too.
If you don't like borders and you can
get rid of the damn walls in your house
and you don't need doors on your bedroom
either and we can keep an eye on you
whenever we want and so much for
borders.
One of the things that really differs
between liberals and conservatives
between the left and the right is the
right is in the right legs,
tight borders between things.
It's part of being conscientious at
every level,
conceptually,
sexually,
familiarly,
provincially,
nationally.
The right says,
look,
let's keep.
Let's keep the borders between things
pretty distinct and the left says,
yeah,
maybe not because some of those borders
are in the wrong place and a little bit
more free flow of information wouldn't
be a bad thing,
and the thing is that right,
but so are the Conservatives and that's
why you have to talk.
It's like,
well,
we've got some borders.
That's a good thing.
Maybe some of them need to be moved
around a little bit and that's what the
political dialogue is for,
but that doesn't mean that borders
themselves are a bad idea.
They're a great idea because without
borders,
everything Nash's into the same
untenable state of undifferentiated
chaos and you can't live in that.
And so the people who are trying to tear
down the borders conceptually,
politically and practically what they
want is the chaos that that would bring
the either want that or they're too
foolish to know that their pursuits will
produce that.
So let's,
let's,
let's be a little bit clear that if you
stand up and say,
yeah,
borders,
they're okay,
they've got their problems,
but they're okay.
That doesn't make you a bigot beyond
redemption.
It just makes you someone with some
sense and it's actually okay to be
someone with some sense limits on
immigration are also reasonable while we
need to figure out what those limits are
and that's what the bloody political
dialogue is for,
but the fact that it should be limited
to some degree is also reasonable.
Otherwise,
why not just open the borders and let
everybody come in?
Well,
the reason you don't do that is because
a complex system cannot tolerate
extensive transformation over too short
a period of time.
Now you want immigrants to come in,
especially if they're the sorts of
immigrants who are likely to contribute
properly to the success of your policy
and lots of immigrants do that.
I mean,
I think the vast majority,
for example,
of entrepreneurs in the United States
come from the Indian subcontinent,
so great.
You know,
bring them over.
They're highly educated,
they're extraordinarily productive.
They make lots of new businesses and
then they pump money like back,
like mad back in India.
Good deal.
But that doesn't mean that we have.
We have our arms are open to everyone
immigration policy because it's complete
rubbish.
All that means is you're not thinking
about it,
so when here's the coded to that for
conservatives.
Here's something I've been thinking
about this a lot lately.
It should not be assumed that citizens
have societies that have not evolved
functional individual rights predicated
polities will hold values in keeping
with such qualities.
So we could say,
look,
there are a lot of countries in the
world that are not governed well,
the vast majority of them,
right,
and they've been not governed well
forever,
and to me that means that there's
something wrong with the values that are
held collectively by the people who've
established those policies.
Well,
you shouldn't be naive and assume that
merely because you moved them to a new
country,
they're going to let their innate
democratic longings,
Florida.
It doesn't work that way.